you know what George told me just now
before the podcast is that live in a
mental prison mental prison yeah you
said that live in a mental prison I'm
just saying let Kanye tweets inspire you
to break out of your mental prisons
don't look at what he like what he's
tweeting look at like the loads you can
gain from what he's tweeting if you live
in a mental prison break out of it I
don't live it I don't no one lives in a
mental [ __ ] prison dude you know I
took some time I was like what mental
prisons do I believe in you how would I
even know if I live in a mental prison
you just gotta think about it what are
one of yours so a yeah what do ya what
how are you living in the mental prison
uh I don't think big enough you know I'm
thinking too small I'm only thinking
about like next week think about five
years from now what's possible like
chief that's what a [ __ ] prison
because I think that you should stay
present maybe you're not thinking big
enough but I think that thinking too far
ahead can be I'm thinking about it too
small about what's possible okay I
understand here's my mental prison I
okay yes I have certain beliefs and I
know that other people have the opposite
beliefs than I do right you know I
believe in you know I'm a bleeding-heart
liberal and it's sad to say that I am
you know I believe that you know we
should be able to take some of our money
and help others with it I don't think
I'll ever shake that I believe that I
just have this inner paranoia that
corporations and the people that are
running this country are selfish and
they're greedy and that they they don't
share their wealth and I want to put a
kink in that you know I like when I see
a movie I like when the little man comes
up yeah like when the black guy from
Independence Day he's a little man like
him and Joe
the guy from Jurassic Park fly yet so
you know the black guy from friends
prints the fresh print you know all his
work with fresh prints and the fly right
they got into a rope like you know
abandoned station and that one jellyfish
movie the blue octopus ring movie yeah
that and they went up
they harbored on to Italy in the harbor
but they latched on to the main
mothership right and they put a virus in
the spacecraft right and they gave it a
sickness right and they really escaped
and save the day right when I see movies
like that I want the little man to come
up all right they would have never
thought of that if they were in a mental
prison of like what's possible I have a
mental prison
what's your amazing in your nose right
now yeah it's really weird coming out
there goes I have two options
well I can either you can either watch
my nose drip like a waterfall or I can
plug it it's natural though I got a
[ __ ] plug it I'm sorry there is
nothing there is no recourse no other
recourse my mental prison is I'm an idea
machine but I cannot I have no
follow-through and the reason I don't
have follow-through is because I don't
have I'm so afraid to fail not even just
fail in general but my for instance yes
I think that in that sense because I do
have a perfectionist gene you [ __ ]
talk right it's okay that I cannot I'd
rather not know if I cannot know the end
of it because I already know it's not
gonna be perfect so I don't even [ __ ]
try and I don't [ __ ] you know it
drives me crazy and I sit here and I
just have a mountain of ideas and I'm
sure you guys have known me long enough
to you're like wow come on that's a lot
but then I never [ __ ] put pen to
paper and I want to apologize to know
you sound great because you just ignited
something within my soul my friend and I
did something within my soul my friend
and what that is is that you're right I
did live in a mental prison but I'm a
couple of weeks ago maybe we could go I
saw something on the net and it opened
my world up and I think I took a step
out of my present prison I was it
I was watching British Got Talent listen
to what I'm saying okay I love I love
watching talent shows oh yeah boy shows
everyone knows that about me and I was
watching these two Vietnamese brother
right
and you why people out there work you
can call them whatever you want okay I
know what no I know what they're trying
to think in their heads but when I'm
saying to you right now Bobby knows I
know all right and these two brothers
are winners and they're creative and
they're strong and they're evolved and
they're better than all of them one
brother
okay somewhere detail and so I was
explained to George earlier this week
that I saw this and what the act was
this eventually what happens is one
Vietnamese brother right goes on the
head the of another Vietnamese pop
robber right and he balances let's go
sit down sit down what are you talking
about fell off her chair all right
someone Vietnamese brother
it's another Vietnamese brother on his
head so basically to let machen this I
don't even know how to explain it but I
imagine one man standing there right and
and another man his the top of his head
he's balancing the other man and the
other man's backwards right and then
he's walking around with his brother in
that with fashion they go down these
stairs and then they go backwards up
these stairs I'm telling you right now
and I told that to George and George
says me and Brice can do it yeah well
you offered that yeah yeah I said - I
said George I said I said to George I
said I'll give you 40 percent of all
income I make for the rest of my life
hey Ben you and Bryan do do that in six
months though in six months and you said
yes we can yeah no apparatus nothing we
get exactly the same thing they have if
they have a head apparatus it's hidden
by their hair we get it we don't have a
yes yeah I'm you're saying if they have
one they don't have one but if they did
okay okay you get the exactly same thing
they have yeah but we have to do exactly
what they did
okay okay they got advanced to like the
semifinals or whatever yeah no they did
it oh they didn't but they got passed
through right so like what is their next
act
aside from walking around with his
brother on his top well maybe
does he dead you know the dance maybe
yeah maybe there's more like he puts him
on his head there's a third brother it
comes yeah and then a third brother the
upside-down running man I don't know
what it is I think they did I think they
what they did was and that's a problem
with those shows yeah is they show their
best [ __ ] up front yeah then they get
through and then they panic for two
weeks what else do we do right they
probably get an erection they probably
try different things again erections out
of Valley you know but I don't know no
there's nobody can do it 40%
all income he ever made I don't want the
renegotiation as soon as we're getting
close it's like okay 30% you really blew
and then we you [ __ ] gangly as white
[ __ ] you really actually believe that
you can do it with Bryce you think you
can balance price on your head with the
right amount of money there what the
right motivation yes Wow oh he also said
it's because that him and Bryce are
taller that they can balance better
prices tall it's better for a better for
balance I feel like if you're shorter
it's shorter center of gravity you're
just better when you're shorter cuz you
have your stockier it's like putting to
the bottom person happy but maybe me
tall but I'm upside down
obviously I'm stronger he's too gangly
you know he's got to be up there I'm
upside down
whoa well you know what I did the reason
why I gave you that idea is because um I
haven't had a big laugh in a long time
like your God we're all like
can't breathe kind of a laugh and so I
just wanted to set this up so that I
could like just you know set myself up
for happiness because there's no [ __ ]
way you're gonna be able to do it
there's no way there's no way but I want
you to try please do that please and
please record it he's recorded like the
practice session they're rehearsals it
rehearsals yeah okay what are you
thinking about I'm thinking how to start
where to get the where to get a rope to
get Breyers upside down just to practice
like slowly with like within a few
inches you know just like I'm hiding
upside down then like you know but just
like where I have like three inches
where if I lift up three inches then we
can practice like there and then like
slowly build up yeah okay great that's
great
[Music]